Theatre today I don't believe he beat it
you still don't think he ran a four to
two Sims shefter over here got all the
scoop on Antonio Brown Derek Carr and
Odell Beckham jr. and Jon Gruden on your
team that'll sell tickets in Vegas in a
hurry
[Music]
wildcard playoffs we made it we made a
17 weeks it's the playoffs the regular
season starts now but guess what for New
England Patriots their regular season
man we're gonna get to all the teams
later in the show Alley helping us
figure out Chicago and Philadelphia we
check in with Chris Johnson right our
good buddy
PJ 2k but a t two teams that aren't even
in the playoffs their wide receivers
have taken over the news cycle first
Sims shefter over here got all the scoop
on Antonio Brown and the Pittsburgh
Steelers right it sounds like a mess it
does sound like a mess I don't think
there's any doubt about it you've got
some scoop I do have scoop talking to
pyres X players other people that work
in the organization I've gotten a story
from a number of people and I think the
one thing what did you take away from
the biggest thing is that Antonio Brown
has had dysfunctional issues within that
organization for a while whether it's
being late for meetings or little things
that we saw like we always like a visual
this is a habitual thing we've said this
as people have crucified Odell over the
year that Antonio from the Gatorade
smashing to the Facebook lives to the
insulting the reporter threatening the
reporter to volunteer off the balcony
right it's been constant has been
constant and we're not shocked no we're
not shocked we have heard all of these
stories
I think what's shocking last weekend it
was such a big game they're playing to
get into the playoffs hopefully against
the Cincinnati Bengals there's a
disagreement during a walkthrough on
Wednesday
Antonio Brown felt disrespected about it
he didn't show up for at least two to
three days just didn't show up
didn't show up at all and then came to
the locker room on Sunday expecting to
play and of course they did not let him
do that and then he went out there and
you saw him in his mink coat and he's
the man don't get me wrong he's a baller
supreme yes but he did yes I was told he
left at half-time your big point is yeah
whenever something happens on the
Steelers we point a finger at Mike
Tomlin and say he has no control right
and you're saying exactly right he has
no control
so why are we blaming Tom exactly right
I don't like that mike tomlin gets the
blame for all of these things when you
know he's not the center focus of who
drafted some of these players or
negotiating their contracts or
negotiating to the point where there's
so much dead money right now then people
go well they're gonna trade in Tony
alright no they're not
they can't trade in Antonio Brown and
they trade him or cut him they are gonna
be on the hook for twenty-one million
dollars that's like three or four
quality starting pyres I just hear from
and try and we'll keep exactly right and
deal with them you've been dealing with
them already anyway in comparison right
Odell seems like a choirboy you know a
lot of people have been saying right
cluding you yeah they're gonna trade
them you don't got a quarterback that
can reach him it doesn't make sense
Kettleman has come out and says we're
not gonna trade right but you don't say
well it's early in the offseason I got
to see it to believe it there I mean
yeah I just think there's some things
you know reading the tea leaves or
between the lines right of just what
we've seen first of all I think of the
Mehra family who's close to the Rooney
family in Pittsburgh and they're
probably going hmm
do we really want this issue to happen
to us two or three years down the road
with Odell Beckham jr. major stick to me
just thinking as a football person and I
know there'll be a demand for him and a
lot of his money's been paid already so
they're gonna go oh well that's not so
bad to trade from so let us say it's a
possibility let's open up the Sims chaos
generator guys I'm gonna turn this wheel
and we're gonna put out four teams that
Odell could possibly go char we're gonna
start off in Indianapolis yes yes the
Indianapolis Colts they have so much
money you have an offensive line you got
a course Andrew Luck right you don't I
don't think they need necessarily to go
out and get a big-time running back
because they got two or three in the
rotation that are good already
but you pair up an Odell Beckham jr.
with Andrew Luck on the other side of T
Y Hilton whoa watch out that is a young
nucleus that could grow together and
really be special I got another young
quarterback right crank crank crank
crank
Josh Allen oh I mean that to me I just
want to say that Odell and Buffalo is
not a visual that I thought I'd see if
he'd be there to mink coat right y'all
live in this crap right Josh LM throwing
to Odell I I think that's where I look
at it yes the commercial appeal is not
going to be there about the
hello bills but the the New York Giants
if they are trading him away aren't
gonna be worried about what his
commercial appeal is in this situation
but I look at the team like the Buffalo
Bill had a lot of money assets and then
a quarterback who has an arm like
Patrick mahomes and big-time talent that
we saw we'll see where it all adds up
but there's no weapons there to support
him right now and I'm just saying that's
one guy that could help
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh our favorite coach
in the NFL that's right I'll Shannon
yeah we thought you thought yeah maybe
the Niners before the contract got done
yeah I though I'm gonna throw another
one in there with it I'm gonna put the
Bay Area in general the Raiders and the
49ers ideally be in this conversation
first of all let's just talk about the
Raiders going to Vegas and you got Derek
Carr and Odell Beckham jr. and Jon
Gruden on your team that'll sell tickets
in Vegas in a hurry okay and I just
think they need the weapons and Jon
Gruden can use them in that type of
offense same thing with Kyle Shanahan
and the San Francisco 49ers I think that
could make sense and certainly make a
splash for the 49ers to go here we come
for our playoff run in 2019 levia Odell
and Antonio all go to the Colts Andrew
Luck has a field and throws for 75
touchdown passes
hi I'm Tim Bailey and you're watching
Sam's and left cope usually I do the
introductions but I this is you this is
your guy this is my guy I mean this is
the original CJ 2k my man right here I
didn't know what to expect when I saw
this guy in person as a player like he
was a rookie when he was a rookie in
that and in training camp I was with the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers so I hit that team
as he'll tell you had a bunch of Texas
guys on the Tennessee Titans team and
they kept telling me man this Chris
Johnson is a Balder man we've never seen
anybody so fast and I was like yeah blah
blah blah but then I got there and yes
one of the most special talents I've
ever been around and in your memories of
Chris Simms man he used to talk trash to
me before every game stop okay I think
it was probably like wheat or wheat like
oh come on I was I think I had I went
400 yards like rice like come on man on
telecine these 10 fits in your you're on
break or something long I bet that
saying game
Linda broke 480 and I came right back
and broke for like 70 City Kansas City
Kansas City Kansas City like that's when
the smash and dash thing took off but it
did what those two big runs yeah yeah
and it was I think that's a nickname
that I feel like they try to give to a
lot of duo's now but you guys were
smashing yeah yeah we started that they
asked us like what was our name yes
England it was like we smash and - right
he came over smash - then ever since
then they just started calling us there
every week smash and - okay we have
Mendel
I mean characters and Lyndell especially
a character that's an all-time running
back room yes and and Lyndell we can put
him on blast now cuz his careers over he
was late a lot okay I mean late a lot
right like and always had a different
excuse right how much weight goes is
true like if we had a 8:30 meeting
Lyndell wasn't I felt like never there
at 8:30 never and this is every day I
mean at least once or twice a week okay
and he'd always have some great excuse I
mean great what do you think his best
excuse was was one you remember you
remember any good mother
yeah we were he was late one time he
came in he was like man I had to pull
over to the gas station bathroom my son
was hurt I had used just so he his
excuse was I took a crap and I had thank
revenue and then when he says that the
team explodes no actually because it's a
serious setting I mean we're all shaking
her head like what a bunch of bullcrap
that is but there's nothing we can say
cuz Jeff Fisher is still the head coach
and he's down in front of the room and
we're not gonna butt in that
conversation so I want to ask mr. four
to four who's the fastest guy in the NFL
right now
okay is it unreal how fast he is
he's very I mean like I'm not trying to
disrespect you or Joey Galloway or Deion
Sanders but he is the fastest guy I've
ever seen maybe he's a second okay I
want to say the fast you invasive asses
I know you're gonna take yourself of
course
of course you should what what was what
was bigger the two thousand or the four
to four
mm mmm but the four to four we had never
seen before you got the watch made all
that yeah when you saw John Ross beat
the four to four i emoji that's what he
sent out Suzy ran the type remember that
official time hadn't came in and he
tweeted I emoji was there all of you
that was like I hope that gets corrected
and it's actually a four to five
probably a part of me still for today I
don't believe he beat it you round up or
two to know when you look okay for once
when you look at the okay I put it off
on them at the end right that's fast
yeah number two is when have it ever
took that long for the first time may
take a long time you're right Wow that
it was rigged
they probably made with your che
probably got side of tired of Joe never
highlight although yeah they probably
got tired of nowhere being there fare
like that the compound was getting
boring they needed more attention either
more it's a conspiracy theory guy this
is one of the best ones I've ever heard
I'm telling you I don't believe it I
have to imagine you would go out and
people would be like in the club going
I'll race you in the parking lot yeah
all the time all the time that's just an
area where everywhere but dumbest crap
ever yeah
yeah they don't know what they're
messing with since you are the master of
forty times we have some very famous
running clips from movies that we'd like
you to watch and tell us what you think
they're 40 times would be okay
we're gonna start off first
this is the scene from get out watch my
man run we all remember the scenes and
here's the crap out of this and running
straight Adam turns the last time that
form is phenomenal his elbows are
imperfect but that was for a while right
that was it for when you're running
you're admitting that someone may be
faster than you yeah probably
Wow yeah all right next one is Mission
Impossible it is the crazy lunatic that
is Tom Cruise what do you think Tom
Cruise's for tea time was in Mission
Impossible yeah that's right you're
being generous
he's got the duck feet a little bit yes
right yeah I mean he's like for a dish
to mean no way he's beating me in a race
he's going all the stairs and everything
yeah it's going down all right next one
up much better movie bad boys the king
that is Will Smith run it with a gun in
hand and then he's got a save Lord
Lawrence what do you think the top speed
that will hit there was he for a right
there for a real low on Will Smith now
to a legendary Runner the Forrest Gump
in the khakis what do you think his top
speed there was you look forward to
right now for Ted Cosby right there
right there right and then the last one
is Michael Cera in Superbad as he's
gonna run from the cops here to the side
crazy fast I know how definitely and
thank you all right so let's recap these
you have get out as your leader at four
one coming in second place Forrest Gump
at four to third place Mission
Impossible Tom Cruise at four three Will
Smith shockingly gets fourth place at a
four eight and Michael Cera
appropriately five five do you agree
with his rankings I do I think I thought
maybe he was a hair nice to Tom Cruise I
agree but other than that it's pretty
good
get out beats Forrest Gump yeah are we
going into the sunken place well good
luck to you my Frankie as a pleasure
talking to thank you
way to go
it is time for the playoffs and this is
where the gamblers make their most money
Sims is usually the Oracle this time of
year but we're not giving up hope on
Ally and honestly there's one wild card
game more than the rest that matters
more to me and I need to know who Ally's
taking seven and four on the season Ally
congratulations one 1905 for picking the
Cowboys over the Giants I can finish the
regular season with a win okay
but this game means a lot to me Eagles
at bears okay bears are favored by six
it's the primetime game of wildcard
weekend Eagles Eagles that bears a
touchdown really what we almost our
touchdown okay in Chicago insanity I
don't like that you're talking about the
Bears cuz I don't like your Eagles so
much so that I'm going against him I'm
gonna biz is it just cuz you don't like
my Eagles no I think the Bears are
better team okay I think going into
Chicago Philly's gonna have a tough time
final message to Sims
I hope you're going with me this week I
hope so I went to Ally for a little bit
of confidence I doubt I do last week he
won he took the Cowboys oh good but
here's the thing
he's taking the Bears over the Eagles
she's taking the Bears there's minus six
against the eagle oh gosh
six points that's a lot I didn't realize
that's what it is the Bears are gonna
beat your Eagles I just hope you know
that so deal with it okay have you not
learned deal with the advance the hell
Bay and Nick Foles
and how he how have you not learned how
to close the yearbook and that was last
year in this ain't this year okay
they're better than you they're like you
guys last year I just want to say if
there's a team that I get to face right
it's a team that has Mitchell strabinsky
as a quarterback playoff game okay
that's what I'm saying
okay this is a team that's going we won
the division and the Eagles are going we
know what it takes to get there there's
nothing in there right no you don't
value that at all well no there's
something there there's battle-tested
football so you would take the Bears is
six points I don't think I would take
the Bears I would take your Eagles to
stay within six but I would say there's
within six yeah
let's talk about the other games cuz
this one we may watch the game together
and he's just gonna berate me the entire
time right but the Saturday games and
the Sunday games are great less awesome
quick yeah
cult set Texans waffle for the Texas
that they had to play this team again I
think so because we always talk about
the Texans had their great D line that
kind of gets you know muted against and
they let a big play it's a great old
line of the Colts in the passing game
right which you know the Texans pass the
offense is horrible that's where it's
scary but they do have to show an Lots
in yes and that's where it gets scary as
well if you had to pick one - I'm going
cult I would see Hawks at cowboy very
similar teams that are obsessed with
running the ball right obsessed they
don't do a lot on defense there their
whole mantra both of those teams is
we're gonna about physical us we're
gonna out-hustle you we're not gonna
mess up Dallas this passing game
defensive coordinator used to be there
exactly right see there's a lot of fun
going Cowboys I am to dirt like I said
they're the same team really
schematically and the way they approach
the game I just think the Dallas is the
better version and they're at home and
you're not the same team on the rover
cisely damn I wanted you to take the
opposite their Chargers Raven right we
match a week 15 I don't know where I'm
going here I really don't you know I'm
gonna team I'm going to ride the Ravens
though just because they're at home and
it's a charge or whatever you go in that
game I'm going up okay that's the game I
feel I have no idea exactly right that
is a coin flip to me I don't know where
it gets Phillip Rivers having seen the
defense yeah changes it up and if you're
right I trust him more if the game on
the line they have to Lamar Jackson yet
it's on the road and it's cold so those
changes and the Chargers are seven and
one on the road yeah I got you and there
are girls bears you guys win Bears win
if the Eagles win right right I can't go
down that road all I'm saying is chicken
Alshon revenge game in Chicago followed
up by Darren Sproles revenge game in New
Orleans ski mask is my ski last year I
wrote it's so hard for you guys and this
year I'm reading so hard against you
Italia for sense peace out homies go man
f koe man and fly the road to Chicago
okay thanks bro hey no problem sure the
games a lot do you remember our coach
Jeff Fischer parachuting onto the field
yeah a little bit they told us to go out
in the practice field and we're all kind
of like just sitting there like what the
hell he doing why are we out here early
and all sudden there was this like black
speck in the sky it was a helicopter way
up and then all of a sudden he came down
and I just I just I'm still blown away
by I'm really asking you a question I'm
just going like isn't that unbelievable
yeah definitely unbelievable he did have
icicles
on his mustache though hey what's up
homies thanks for watching subscribe to
the B our YouTube channel man you're
such a millennial also while you're here
we have a lot of other videos check them
out and then what time does our show
come out Wednesday 8:00 p.m. be there or
be square he ruined it it was really
close